-My first guest is one of the
biggest stars on the planet.
His children's book,
"Marcus Makes a Movie,"
is available for preorder.
He also is starring in
the Netflix movie "Fatherhood,"
which begins streaming
June 18th.
Here is the very funny
Kevin Hart!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, my man!
Oh!
Yeah!
That's what I'm talkin' about.
Ah!
I miss seeing you, bud.
-I know, man.
I'm used to walking out there,
high-fiving you, sitting down...
-Right.
-...putting my legs up...
-Yeah.
-...watching the audience.
There was a thing --
I used to do a thing, man.
I can't do my thing.
-I know, we had a thing!
But we can do our thing
in there.
I like your shirt, by the way.
-I don't have on pants.
-No, no, I know!
I didn't ask that, Kevin.
I did not ask that.
-I know, but I want you to know,
'cause I'm honest.
I don't have on pants.
-I know, but it's not -- no.
You say that every interview.
-Don't ask me to stand up.
-No, I'm not!
Please don't.
No, no, do not stand up.
Don't encourage him, please.
-All right, I'm gonna do it.
-No, audience!
-You got the blur button ready?
-No, no, no, no, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Okay.
-Don't stand up.
-Okay.
All right. Okay.
-I'm gonna need a bigger
thing than that, sorry.
I'm gonna need, like, a big --
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Please don't stand up, bud.
Hey.
-How you doing?
-I'm doing good, pal.
I do really miss you,
having you here,
'cause you're always super fun.
I want to talk about --
You have so many things going
on, so many great projects.
"Marcus Makes a Movie."
But, I want to talk to you --
Since last I talked to you,
you had a baby girl.
Congratulations.
-Yes, man, yes.
-Hey!
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Another baby.
Another one.
Father of four now.
-You guys ready
to see something really cute?
You ready to see this baby?
Oh, my God.
Look at this.
Kaori.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Look at this.
-Oh, my goodness.
That is --
She looks like a doll.
-Yeah.
My little Cabbage Patch doll.
-She's so cute.
-My little Cabbage Patch.
-She really is.
How is it --
What's it like
having four kids around?
-Uh, loud.
Very loud.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-You know?
-A lot of stuff.
-I can't even lie, man.
You know what?
It's a feeling like no other.
I have embraced fatherhood...
-Yeah.
-...you know, with everything
that I have, man.
And, you know,
I got a teenager now.
My oldest is 16.
My -- My son, Hendrix,
is about to be 14.
My son Kenzo is 3,
and now Kaori, she's 8 months.
It's just --
It's insane sometimes
when you are in a home,
and you look around you,
and you look at this --
this thing --
this thing that now exists
that has such a tight
and close-knit bond, man.
And, you know,
I didn't come from
the mom and dad
in the same household,
and the family
that ate dinner every night.
So, the fact that, you know,
I now have broke the --
the mold and created that and
started that, it means a lot.
It means the world to me.
-Yeah, good for you.
-I love to see it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, man.
-Your daughter is 16.
And you just --
She got her driver's license,
and you got her a car.
-Yeah.
-You bought her a car.
Now --
-Yeah.
-Did you get a car
when you were 16?
-No, I didn't get no car!
You know damn well
I didn't get no car, Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
I didn't get no car.
You want to know what I got?
I got a bucket.
-Oh, you did not get a bucket.
Come on.
-Yeah, I got a bucket.
I got a bucket,
and in that bucket was nothing.
-There you go.
-If you want something --
If you want something,
you go do some work
and fill the bucket up.
That's what I got.
-So you're saying this kid --
this kid didn't have a car.
He just had a bucket.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow. Wow.
Where'd you get that?
Hmm?
Jesus Christ.
I'm sorry.
First of all,
I want to apologize
to the audience
for my hairline in that --
in that picture.
That was a difficult time.
That's when my mom
was cutting my hair with a bowl.
True story.
[ Laughter ]
She would put a bowl on my head
and go around it.
But, no, I did not have a car.
My first car was
a white Trans Am
that my brother got for me
when I was like --
I think I was like 19.
I didn't get it in high school.
We didn't have cars
in high school...
-No.
-...in Black neighborhoods.
That wasn't a gift.
No, man.
-No.
-We had bikes.
Maybe -- Maybe a bike.
And if you rode that to school,
you weren't coming home with it.
Somebody would steal it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Somebody would steal it.
Let's talk about this.
Can we talk about your book?
Children's book.
-Please do, man.
-This is great, man.
"Marcus Makes a Movie."
I think it's great.
I think it's funny.
It's got a great message
for kids.
Basically saying,
"Hey, stick with it.
If you have a dream, work hard.
And if you work hard,
you can get somewhere."
-I mean, this is --
this is an opportunity, man,
to really motivate
and inspire our youth.
You know, I feel like
this generation
needs to truly understand
that the word "no" is just that.
It's a word.
And our stories
are very important.
I heard "no" a lot,
you know, on my journey.
And the road to success
is a long one.
A lot of doors
get closed in your face.
A lot of roads
have blocks at the end of them,
and you gotta figure out
ways around them.
And that's what life is about.
It's about pivoting.
It's about understanding
that your dream is just that.
It's yours.
And your belief in you
and your understanding of what
you can do is just that.
It's yours, and nobody can ever
tell you that that's not true.
Nobody can ever tell you
that it's not good enough.
In "Marcus Makes a Movie,"
it's about a kid
that had a dream that --
that kept getting denied.
People kept telling him that
his dream would never happen.
And he was determined
to achieve the goal
within his dream that he found
a way to do it himself.
And it became
such an amazing thing for him
and an amazing thing
for his family
because as he grew
and as he started to understand
that he was capable of doing
what he put his mind to,
he became a much,
much better individual.
And that's what I want our
generation to understand.
That's what
I want these kids to understand.
You can be whatever
you want to be in life,
as long as you believe it
and you put your mind to it.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]